FIRST, THE MADNESS OF VOTING
AGAINST YOURSELF.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
SOME AMERICANS MAY BE THINKING
THAT VOTING FOR JOE BIDEN IN
NOVEMBER WILL BE A VOTE AGAINST
TRUMP, BUT MAYBE IT IS TIME TO
LOOK AT THINGS A DIFFERENT WAY,
MAINLY IF YOU VOTE FOR BIDEN,
WHAT EXACTLY WILL YOU BE VOTING
FOR?
HOW WILL AMERICA CHANGE?
FIRST THING YOU HAVE TO REALIZE
IS ANYTHING BIDEN SAYS ABOUT
BEING TOUGH ON CHINA OR PUSHING
MADE IN AMERICA STUFF IS A TOTAL
LIE.
BIDEN HAS SPENT HALF A CENTURY
AND POLITICS INCLUDING EIGHT
YEARS AS VICE PRESIDENT TO SHOW
US HE WAS AN ECONOMIC POPULACE?
I DON’T THINK SO.
THIS LATTER-DAY ATTEMPT TO
REBRAND HIMSELF AS SOME SORT OF
LIBERAL AND TRADE MANUFACTURING
IS A COMPLETE AND UTTER FORCE.
INSTEAD OF AMERICA FIRST,
BIDEN’S POLICIES HAVE ALWAYS PUT
AMERICAN WORKERS LAST.
AND AFTER BIDEN’S SPEECH THE DAY
BEFORE, COME ON, YOU MIGHT BE
WONDERING, WHERE HAVE YOU HEARD
ALL OF THAT BEFORE?
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SPENDS
TAXPAYER’S MONEY.
WE SHOULD USE IT TO BUY AMERICAN
PRODUCTS AND SUPPORT AMERICAN
JOBS.
>> WE WILL ALWAYS LIVE BY TWO
SIMPLE RULES "BY AMERICANS AND
HIGHER AMERICANS."
>> Laura: TRUMP, OF COURSE
HE’S RIGHT THROUGH WHAT BIDEN’S
IS TRYING TO DO.
>> HE PLAGIARIZED ME BUT HE CAN
NEVER PULL IT OFF.
HE LIKES PLAGIARIZING.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, LITTLE
JOKE WITH BIDEN PROBLEM WITH
THAT SPEECH YEARS AGO.
BIDEN’S PROGRESSIVE CHEERLEADERS
KNOW THAT TRUMP WILL EMBRACE
NATIONALISM.
IT’S ONE OF HIS STRONGEST
APPEALS.
THEY HAVE TRIED TO CO-OPT THE
MESSAGE.
>> HE’S BEING VERY INTENTIONAL
ABOUT WHO’S BEEN LEFT OUT OF THE
ECONOMY.
WE ARE REALLY ENCOURAGING
EVERYBODY AND GIVING THEM
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS ECONOMY.
IT WILL BE TRANSFORMATIVE.
>> Laura: TRANSFORMATIVE!
[LAUGHTER]
UNIQUE CHRIS WRAY TO LOOK AT
BIDEN’S LONG RECORD A STAUNCH,
UNREPENTANT GLOBALIST ON TRADE,
ON IMMIGRATION AND OF COURSE ON
FOREIGN AFFAIRS.
HE’S BEEN ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE
OF TRUMP ON EVERY MAJOR POLICY
BATTLE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL INSTALL
GLOBALIST AND KEY POSITIONS IN
THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE
PENTAGON, TAKING US BACK TO THE
OBAMA DAYS HAVE CONSTANTLY
APOLOGIZING TO THE WORLD FOR OUR
PAST SINS AND GIVING CHINA AND
EUROPE WHATEVER THEY WANT
BASICALLY.
REMEMBER BACK IN 2011, BIDEN WAS
ACTUALLY ROOTING ON CHINA.
>> THERE IS A DEBATE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND QUITE FRANKLY
THROUGHOUT MOST OF THE REST
WHETHER RISING CHINA WAS IN THE
INTEREST OF THE UNITED STATES
AND THE WIDER WORLD.
AS A YOUNG MEMBER OF THE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE, I WROTE AND
I SAID WHAT AND I BELIEVED THEN
WHAT I BELIEVE NOW, THAT A RISE
IN CHINA IS A POSITIVE, POSITIVE
DEVELOPMENT.
NOT ONLY FOR CHINA, BUT FOR
AMERICA AND THE WORLD AT LARGE.
>> Laura: [LAUGHTER]
JUST THAT LINE ALONE SHOULD
COMPLETELY DISQUALIFY HIM FROM
THE PRESIDENCY.
HOW DID THAT WORK OUT FOR
HONG KONG, JOE?
COULD HE HAVE BEEN MORE WRONG ON
ISSUES?
AND FOR A SECOND DO YOU THINK IT
WILL COME DOWN FOR THE LEFT?
THE LEFT WILL BE EMBOLDENED AND
NOT CHASED BY A BIDEN WIN.
RETRIBUTION WILL BE A DID A
DIVIDEND FOR THE SQUAD AND THE
BIDEN ERA.
AND IT WILL JUST GET WORSE.
THEY DON’T WANT YOU TO WORRY
ABOUT CANCEL CULTURE, IN FACT,
AOC SAID CHECK YOUR PRIVILEGE
TWEETING.
THE TERM CANCEL CULTURE COMES
FROM ENTITLEMENT.
YOU ARE NOT ACTUALLY CANCELED,
YOU ARE JUST BEING CHALLENGED,
HELD ACCOUNTABLE, OR UNLIKE.
TELL THAT TO THOSE WHO LOST
THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
WE WILL TALK TO A MAN WHO IS
BEING SUBJECT TO THE CANCEL
CULTURE IN JUST A FEW MINUTES.
YOU THINK IT IS ALL BACK NOW,
JUST WAIT UNTIL A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
IF ANYONE, INCLUDING ANY COMPANY
DOES SOMETHING THE LEFT DOESN’T
LIKE, THEY WILL COME UNDER DOJ
SCRUTINY.
IN THE BILL OF RIGHTS, IT’S NOT
GOING TO DO MUCH GOOD FOR YOU.
AFTER ALL, THAT WAS WRITTEN BY
DEAD, OLD SLAVE OWNERS.
MOMENTS LIKE THE TEA PARTY WILL
BE TREATED, I DON’T KNOW LIKE
MOMENTS FOR DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
BLACK DOMINIC
"BLACK LIVES MATTER," THEY WILL
BE TREATED LIKE HEROES.
RELIGIOUS PEOPLE, THE ONES THAT
DON’T GO ALONG WITH THE RADICAL
LEFT WILL BE INVESTIGATED FOR
HATE CRIMES.
HECK, BIDEN ALREADY THREATENED
TO RESCIND THE OBAMACARE
EXEMPTION FOR THE SUPREME COURT
DECISION THE OTHER DAY.
HOMESCHOOLERS, FORGET IT.
YOU WILL FACE SUCH STRICT
CONTROLS, THEY WILL GO BACK TO
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
COLLEGE AND HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS
TEAMS, THEY WILL BE IN TROUBLE
AND MEDIA COMPANIES, THEY WILL
FACE PRESSURE BY THE FCC AND
OTHER REGULATORY BODY.
AND IF YOU TAKE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO COURT BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO CHALLENGE THE STUFF,
YOU WILL FIND THAT IT HAS AT
LEAST FIVE JUSTICES IN
WASHINGTON TO ACT AS A
RUBBER-STAMP.
MEANWHILE, THE LAWS ON THE BOOKS
THAT THEY DON’T LIKE WILL BECOME
MEANINGLESS.
NO MORE ENFORCEMENT OF THE
IMMIGRATION OR DRUG LAWS.
AND OF COURSE, CRIME WILL ARISE
AS COPS ARE TAKEN OFF THE
STREETS AND REPLACED WITH
LEFT-WING SOCIAL WORKERS AND
THERAPIST.
BIDEN HAS ALREADY MOVED AWAY AND
WAY, WAY, WAY TO THE LEFT ON
THAT ISSUE.
>> THE LAST THING YOU NEED IS A
HUMVEE COMING IN, LIKE THE
MILITARY INVADING.
THEY DON’T KNOW ANYBODY AND THEY
BECOME THE ENEMY.
>> CAN WE AGREE THAT WE CAN
REDIRECT SOME OF THE FUNDING?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY!
>> Laura: WOW, AND GOOD LUCK
COMPLAINING ABOUT ANY OF THIS TO
THE PRESS.
AFTER ALL, NOTHING MORE AT THIS
POINT THAN THE PROPAGANDA ARM OF
THE DNC.
IF BIDEN ACTUALLY WINS, THEY
WILL WORK HARDER TO PROTECT HIM.
>> THERE IS NO SCENARIO WHERE
DONALD TRUMP EVEN COMPETES WITH
JOE BIDEN WHO DRIFTS EMPATHY.
>> WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
RECENTLY ON TV WITH A DIFFERENT
SPEECH.
YOU POINT OUT JUST THE EMPATHY,
THE BIDEN EMPATHY.
>> WE REALLY HEARD FROM HIM.
HE WAS TRYING TO SAY TO PEOPLE,
LOOK, I SEE YOU.
I’M FEELING YOUR PAIN.
>> Laura: BUT WAIT, I KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
HOW CAN THE WEALTHY ACTUALLY
SUPPORT BIDEN IF IT IS A VIRTUAL
CERTAINTY THAT PRIMAL
SKYROCKETS, TICKETS WILL GO UP.
COME ON, THE RITUAL ALWAYS
FIGURE A WAY TO SCORE AWAY THEIR
MONEY AND ALWAYS FIND A WAY TO
BE SHIELDED BY PRIVATE SECURITY
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY.
THAT HIS WIFE.
THAT IS THE WAY IT WORKS IN
COUNTRIES LIKE MEXICO AND
GUATEMALA.
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE HEADED
UNDER BIDEN.
FOR A LONG TIME, MANY OF YOU
HAVE BEEN VERY HAPPY THAT YOU
DON’T HAVE TO LIVE IN LEFT-WING
CITIES LIKE BALTIMORE, NEW YORK
OR SAN FRANCISCO.
BUT JUST A FEW MONTHS, YOU MAY
FIND OUT WHAT IT’S LIKE.
FINALLY, LET’S NOT FORGET A VOTE
FOR BIDEN IS A VOTE TO ERASE THE
HISTORY, NATIONAL MEMORY AND OUR
TRADITION.
WHICH BRINGS US TO THE RIOTS.
MOST PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT OR
FRUSTRATED ON THE ONGOING
DESTRUCTION BUT MOST OF IT IS
CONTAINED IN AREAS WHERE WRITERS
FEEL SAFE.
ST. LOUIS, CHICAGO WILL NEVER
ARREST AND PROSECUTE THESE
THUGS.
YET THAT IS ONLY TRUE US SO LONG
THE REPUBLICANS HOLD THE
WHITE HOUSE.
IF THE LEFT GETS CONTROL OF THE
DOJ, THE WRITERS WILL FEEL SAFE
FROM PROSECUTION ALMOST ANYWHERE
IN FACT THEY WILL KNOW ANYONE
WHO INTERFERES WITH THEM WILL
RISK FEDERAL INVESTIGATION.
BIDEN WON’T HAVE TO ORDER PEOPLE
TO DO MUCH OF ANYTHING LIKE
WHAT, BLOW UP MOUNT RUSHMORE?
NO, HE’S NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
HE JUST WON’T DO ANYTHING TO
STOP OR PUNISH THE FOLKS WHO TRY
TO.
AS NANCY PELOSI SAYS --
>> I DON’T CARE THAT MUCH ABOUT
THE STATUES.
>> A MOB IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT.
>> LET THEM DO WHAT THEY DO.
>> Laura: BEING A CITIZEN IS
THE DUTY AND DUTIES AREN’T
ALWAYS EASY OR FUN TO CARRY OUT.
WELL, THESE DAYS, WHEN THERE SO
MUCH HATRED TOWARDS OUR COUNTRY
AND THE MEDIA, I KNOW IT IS
TEMPTING TO TURN IT ALL OUT AND
SAY, I’M NOT LOOKING AT IT.
HIDE OUR HEADS UNDER THE COVERS
AND WAIT FOR THE STORM TO PASS.
BUT THIS ISN’T A STORM, AND IT’S
NOT GOING TO PASS.
IT IS A VICIOUS AND WELL-FUNDED
MOVEMENT TO TAKE AWAY YOUR POWER
AND YOUR MONEY.
AND GIVE THEM TO PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO CRUSH YOU.
BUT PATRIOTIC AMERICANS ARE
STARTING TO RESIST THESE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, SERIES OF
EDICTS AND ACTIONS OF THEIR
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS.
IN YOUNG AND OLD ALIKE MUST
RESPECTFULLY REFUSE TO SUBMIT TO
THIS NEW NORMAL THAT KEEPS US
OUT OF WORK, OUT OF CHURCHES,
AND OUT OF SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE TO TEACH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ONCE AND FOR
ALL THAT ATTACKING US AND
ALIGNING WITH THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST FRENCH IS GOING TO
COST THEM DEARLY.
WE CAN ABSOLUTELY DO THIS.
WE HAVE BEATEN THE LEFT MANY
TIMES BEFORE AND WE CAN DO IT
AGAIN.
IN NOVEMBER, A VOTE FOR TRUMP IS